This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二的保证。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我将解构我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、体能和培养韧性的标志。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。那是字母开头的TWO. percent，在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。在《回顾历史》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾历史》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的诚实对话，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你必须这样做。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
在IHeart无线电应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我动了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困于爱》播客。当一群女人发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《女朋友们。相信我，宝贝》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. There is really no easy way to say this. Dating in your 20s is hard, especially right now. It feels like a bit of a minefield of people who won't commit, people who seem way too good to be true and it turns out that they actually are. Incompatibility, getting ghosted, dates cancelled last minute, just to name a few experiences
新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们正在解构我们20多岁的心理学。真的没有简单的方法来表达这一点。20多岁约会很难，尤其是现在。感觉就像是一个由不会承诺的人、那些看起来好得不像真的却最终确实如此的人组成的雷区。不兼容，被无缘无故断联，约会最后一分钟取消，这仅仅是其中的几个经历
that I'm sure a lot of us have currently been enduring. when this has kind of been going on for a while and these experiences definitely dominate our dating story or our dating narrative, we can become very detached and very defeated and very passive. And to put it simply, I think we lose our power and our agency in dating. We're no longer as picky as we would like to be. We don't call out disrespect or bad behavior. The whole activity becomes a lot more anxiety.
我相信我们很多人目前都在经历。当这种情况已经持续了一段时间，这些经历绝对主导了我们的约会故事或约会叙事时，我们会变得非常抽离、非常被打败并且非常被动。简而言之，我认为我们在约会中失去了我们的力量和自主权。我们不再像我们希望的那样挑剔。我们不指出不尊重或糟糕的行为。整个活动变得比有趣要焦虑得多。
inducing than it is fun. And I think we get into this really negative headspace of expecting people to disappoint us and then not being surprised when they actually do. I think the biggest way to counteract this mindset and this defeatist reality when it comes to dating is to really come back to ourselves and focus inwards, not just for the sake of our love life, but for the sake of actually loving our own life. And I was speaking about this on mantra recently. mantra for those of you who don't know is my other podcast. It's a lot more spiritual. We talk about a specific affirmation, grounding, saying or mantra every single week. Recently I did an episode on I nurture relationships that enrich my life. And I talked about how something I wish I'd learned sooner
引发的焦虑远多于乐趣。我认为我们进入了一种非常消极的心态，期望人们让我们失望，然后在他们真正这样做时并不感到惊讶。我认为抵制这种心态和这种失败主义的现实的最大方法是真正回到我们自己身上，向内关注，不仅是为了我们的爱情生活，而是为了真正热爱我们自己的生活。我最近在《灵言》上谈到了这一点。对于那些不知道的人来说，《灵言》是我的另一个播客。它要精神得多。我们每周讨论一个特定的肯定、接地、说话或灵言。最近我做了一集关于“我培养丰富我生活的关系”的节目。我谈到了我希望自己早点学到的一些东西
was that dating is meant to be a enjoyable and B, it's meant to be a selfish activity. Truly, dating is actually meant to be rather selfish. We are taught to always be ready to compromise and to be flexible and to be good and to meet everyone's needs. And that's great, fair enough. But I don't think that shouldn't be the case when it comes to trying to find your life partner. Very few decisions are as important. And I think compromise now in the early stages of dating is misery and frustration later on. I wish I'd known that at 21. I wish I'd known that maybe even at 23. But when we really do start to focus on what do I want, how do I want to be treated, what is my vision for love and what would it take for that to be meant, we experience
那就是约会应该是A，令人愉快的，B，它应该是一个自私的活动。真的，约会其实应该相当自私。我们被教导要随时准备妥协，要灵活，要做好人，要满足每个人的需求。这很好，情有可原。但我不认为在试图寻找生活伴侣时应该是这样的。很少有决定如此重要。我认为在约会早期阶段的妥协是后来的痛苦和沮丧。我希望我在21岁时就知道这一点。我希望我甚至在23岁时就知道这一点。但是，当我们真正开始关注我想要什么，我想如何被对待，我对爱的愿景是什么，以及满足这些需要什么时，我们会经历
such a huge and powerful shift that not only makes dating fun, it makes it intentional, and I think it makes it fruitful as well. So today, I want to give you my formula for reclaiming your power in dating and also talk about why it is that we do lose our agency, why repeated rejection and relationship trauma and a scarcity mindset are some of the reasons dating feels so personally hard. And I want to talk about some of the dating dilemmas that you guys have been facing as well. As people in their 20s, some of you reached out with some pretty epic stories,
如此巨大而强大的转变，不仅让约会变得有趣，还让它变得有目的，而且我认为它也变得硕果累累。所以今天，我想把我在约会中夺回力量的公式分享给你们，并且还要谈谈为什么我们会失去自主权，为什么反复的拒绝、关系创伤和稀缺心态是约会让人觉得如此困难的一些原因。我还想谈谈你们一直面临的一些约会困境。作为20多岁的人，你们中的一些人联系我时带有一些非常史诗般的故事，
some pretty frustrating stories to read from my perspective. So I want to talk about exactly how you can bring back your own own control, how you can be in control of those situations. So without further ado, my lovely, lovely listeners, let's get into my guide to reclaiming your power in dating in your 20s and beyond. I want to start out by talking about a time in my own life when I completely abandoned myself to who I was dating, essentially because I thought that their approval and if they liked me and if I was good enough for them that that could turn into love and that could make me happy. And spoil the alert, in reality, it actually took me to a very low point. And I'm sure a lot of you could probably
从我的角度来看，有一些相当令人沮丧的故事可读。所以我想谈谈你究竟如何才能夺回自己的控制权，如何在这些情况下保持控制。所以废话不多说，我可爱的、可爱的听众们，让我们进入我关于在20多岁及以后重新夺回约会力量的指南吧。我想从我生命中的一段时期开始谈起，当时我完全抛弃了自己去迎合我约会的人，本质上是因为我认为他们的认可，如果他们喜欢我，如果我对他们来说足够好，那就能转化为爱，那就能让我快乐。剧透一下，在现实中，它实际上把我带到了一个非常低的低谷。我确信你们中的很多人可能
tell me a similar story. So back in 2021, I was dating like my first really serious boyfriend. And long-time listeners will know that that breakup is really what created the psychology of your 20s. But you know he was great he was a nice guy it just didn't work we broke up and he moved on really really quickly like very quickly and it was this whole story where i was still somewhat under the illusion slash delusion that we were going to get back together and one of my friends had to be like hey he actually has a new girlfriend i think it just put me into the real painful part of relationship grief very, very quickly. I was like, oh, I thought that maybe I would have time, that maybe we could still have this shared experience of grieving and missing each other. And suddenly,
能告诉我一个类似的故事。所以回到2021年，我在约会就像我的第一个真正的严肃男朋友。老听众会知道，那次分手真正造就了《20多岁的心理学》。但你知道他很好，他是个好人，只是行不通，我们分手了，他继续前进了，非常非常快，就像非常快一样，这是一个整个故事，当时我还处于某种幻想/妄想之中，以为我们要复合，我的一个朋友不得不说，嘿，他其实有了一个新女朋友，我想这把我非常非常快地带入了关系悲伤的真正痛苦部分。我想，哦，我以为也许我会有时间，也许我们仍然可以有这种共同悲伤和想念彼此的经历。突然之间，
he's moved on. He's on the next, he's onto the next person. Like, he's, he's all good and fine and dandy. I think that created a bit of a chain reaction in me where I looked at my own life and I was like, how come it was so hard for me to find someone else? I was very, very lonely. I'd been with this person for a while. It was still in Australia. COVID lockdowns. So, you know, I didn't get to do all the fun things that you would normally do post breakup. I didn't get to go out and party with my friends. I didn't get to go out on these days. I didn't get to, you know, just be alive and present and out and about. And so I was feeling very, very rejected. I was feeling very poorly about myself. I think my self-worth was definitely
他向前看了。他继续前进了，他进入了下一个人的生活中。就像，他，他一切都好，很好。我认为这在我体内产生了一点连锁反应，我看着自己的生活，心想为什么我找另一个人会这么难？我非常非常孤独。我和这个人在一起有一段时间了。当时还在澳大利亚。新冠封锁。所以，你知道，我没有做所有你在分手后通常会做的有趣的事情。我没有和朋友出去聚会。我没有去约会。我没有，你知道，只是活着、在场、到处走动。所以我觉得非常非常被拒绝。我对自己的感觉很糟糕。我认为我的自我价值绝对
not an asset that I had at that time. And it was during this period where I thought, okay, maybe I should start dating again. Insane. It was an insane decision because I was four months out of a heartbreak, probably like my most significant one to date. I really had a support network, but it wasn't readily available to me. We had this like little break from lockdown where, you know, everything kind of went back to normal for a couple of months and I went dating. It was almost like a sport for me. I was going on sometimes two dates a day, meeting all these people. And the thing was none of them were particularly nice to me.
不是我在那个时候拥有的资产。正是在这段时期，我想，好吧，也许我应该重新开始约会。疯狂。这是一个疯狂的决定，因为我刚失恋四个月，可能是我迄今为止最重要的一次失恋。我确实有一个支持网络，但它并没有轻易为我所用。我们有这样一个像封锁的小间歇，你知道，一切在几个月内都恢复了正常，我去约会了。对我和来说这几乎就像一项运动。我有时一天去约会两次，见所有人。但问题是他们中没有一个人对我有特别好。
And yet, I don't think there was a single date that I went on where I thought, oh, he's not interested. I should leave this. every single one I was like, potential, potential, potential. I'd basically, I'm going to say it as it is, I'd lost my power. And I met someone during that time, which really, any semblance of agency and control and autonomy I had in this process, any slither of that I had left,
然而，我不认为我去过的任何一次约会中我想过，哦，他对我不感兴趣。我应该离开这个。每一次我都觉得，有潜力，有潜力，有潜力。我基本上，我要直言不讳地说，我已经失去了我的力量。我在那段时间遇到一个人，这真的，我在这个过程中保有的任何一丝自主权和控制权，我剩下的任何一丝残余，
that was finally taken away from me. Because basically, I fell in love with someone very quickly who, had absolutely no interest in loving me back. And everything about our relationship became dictated by what he wanted. We would only hang out at his house. We would only do the dates that he wanted. We only had the label that he wanted to give the relationship, which was not the label that I wanted.
最终都被夺走了。因为基本上，我很快就爱上了一个人，而他，对回爱我绝对没有任何兴趣。我们关系的一切都由他想要的东西决定。我们只在他的房子里闲逛。我们只进行他想要的约会。我们只有他想要给这段关系的标签，而那不是我想要的标签。
And it was very, very painful. And I basically sat in that relationship that wasn't quite a relationship. that wasn't quite a relationship for six months, and it was like I was looking at myself from a high up place, just losing who I was. I was just in this relationship, and I used to be such a forthright advocate for myself. You know, if someone didn't treat me right,
这非常非常痛苦。我基本上在那段算不上关系的关系中坐了六个月，就像我从高处看着自己，只是失去了我是谁。我只是在这段关系中，我曾经是自己如此直言不讳的倡导者。你知道，如果有人对我不好，
I was going to call it out. And in this situation, I just absolutely did not. I just sat there and I just let him say, you know, sometimes really mean things about me, and I let him just be, do, I just let him take control and get whatever he wanted out of the relationship. Whilst I was very clearly sitting there miserable, not getting what I wanted out of the relationship, and you best believe I was not going to advocate for myself because all I wanted
我要大声指出来。而在这种情况下，我绝对没有。我只是坐在那里，任由他说，你知道，有时对我说非常刻薄的话，我任由他去，做，我只是让他掌控并从关系中得到他想要的任何东西。而我明明坐在那里痛苦不堪，没有从关系中得到我想要的东西，你最好相信我不会为自己辩护，因为我想要的全部
in that moment was love. Really, I was not in the place to be dating and I was so fragile and I was so insecure. All I wanted was someone to just like hold me and say I was special or at least, kind of treat me like I have a special a couple of days a week. Needless to say, this relationship, if you can call it a relationship, did not work out. It most certainly did not work out. And we kind of ended things.
在那一刻就是爱。真的，我当时并不处于约会的状态，我太脆弱了，我也太没有安全感了。我想要的全是一个人只是抱抱我，说我很特别，或者至少，一周有几天把我当成特别的人对待。不用说，这段关系，如果你能称之为关系的话，并没有成功。它绝对没有成功。我们差不多结束了这段关系。
And if I thought that I had been in a low place before, the six months post that relationship was so painful and almost like in so, Like, I think about it and I feel so bad for that girl. Because I've spoken about it on the show before, but I couldn't even, like, speak to someone. I just moved to Sydney at the time as well. And obviously, I had to try and meet all these new people. I just didn't feel special at all. I was like, why would anyone want to be my friend?
如果我以为我以前处于低谷的话，那段关系结束后的六个月是如此痛苦，几乎像在如此，像，我想起它，我为那个女孩感到非常难过。因为我在节目中之前谈过它，但我甚至不能，像，和某人说话。我当时也刚搬到悉尼。很明显，我必须尝试结识所有这些新的人。我根本不觉得自己很特别。我想，为什么会有人想成为我的朋友？
Why would anyone want to talk to me right now? I'm just wasting their time. I'm boring them. I have these distinct memories of being at parties that my friends had invited me to, like, the two friends that I had in Sydney at the time. and just not being able to hold a conversation with someone and just being like, oh my God, they're bored, they're bored, they don't want to talk to me anymore, and then leaving the conversation and self-sabotaging. And I just really felt absolutely terrible about myself. And it all stemmed back to the fact that I had let myself be, I don't want to say take an advantage of, I'd let
为什么现在会有人想和我说话？我只是在浪费他们的时间。我在让他们厌烦。我有这些清晰的记忆，在我的朋友邀请我去聚会的派对上，就像我当时在悉尼仅有的两个朋友，却无法和别人进行对话，只是觉得，哦，天哪，他们厌烦了，他们厌烦了，他们不想再跟我说话了，然后离开对话并自我破坏。我真的对自己的感觉绝对糟糕。这一切都源于这样一个事实，即我让自己变成了，我不想说被利用，我让自己
myself be treated badly. Now, I say that, and I don't want people to take that out of context and think that I am saying that anyone who's been through a terrible relationship or even an abusive relationship is responsible for their treatment. Really not the case. Like, really not the case. But I can say in terms of my experience that I knew very clearly and I could feel it bubbling up that I was not being treated right, that I had lost my agency, that I was not happy, that I was not confident and I continued to almost subject myself to that environment and to that emotional environment and situation because I did not feel like I deserved more and the idea of having to go back out there and be single when I had no power as a person who was dating just felt
受到了不好的对待。现在，我这么说，我不希望人们断章取义，认为我在说任何经历过糟糕关系甚至虐待关系的人都要为他们的对待负责。真的不是这样。就像，真的不是这样。但我可以根据我的经历说，我很清楚地知道并且我能感觉到它在沸腾，我没有受到正确的对待，我已经失去了自主权，我不快乐，我不自信，我继续几乎把自己置于那个环境和那个情感环境和情况中，因为我觉得我不配得到更多，而不得不重新出去做单身汉的想法，作为一个在约会时没有权力的人，感觉
absolutely terrible obviously I made it through I made it through and now I'm with someone really, really amazing. Obviously, I've skipped an important chapter here, and that's the chapter that we're talking about today. You know, how did I go from having that terrible relationship, which genuinely broke me, and which I still sometimes sit and think about and think, ooh, out, to where I am now, I've been with my partner for two years, and he is wonderful, and he is spectacular, and he treats me so well, and he is just like genuinely, it's like we are two complete people coming together making each other more whole. Gemma, you know, five years ago would not have imagined that could have occurred.
绝对糟糕。很明显，我挺过来了，我挺过来了，现在我和一个非常非常棒的人在一起。很明显，我在这里跳过了一个重要的章节，这就是我们今天讨论的章节。你知道，我是如何从那段真正打碎了我、我至今有时还会坐下来思考并觉得“哦，天哪”的糟糕关系，走到我现在所处的位置，我已经和我的伴侣在一起两年了，他很好，他很壮观，他对我这么好，他就像真的，就像我们是两个完整的人聚在一起让彼此更完整。杰玛，你知道，五年前绝对不会想象这会发生。
And it's because when it came to dating, I became incredibly selfish. I became independent. I became so focused on what I needed and what I wanted because I really realized after those experiences, no one else was going to advocate for me. you know, everyone else in the dating scheme, in the dating sphere, was putting themselves first. So it was my turn to put myself first. And it was my turn to be bossy about what I wanted. And honestly, it's funny because I think I almost went a little bit too far. My current boyfriend, I almost didn't go on a date with him. It's like a funny story we tell now whereby he like hadn't confirmed plans the day of. And I was texting.
因为在约会这件事上，我变得极其自私。我变得独立。我变得非常专注于自己的需求和欲望，因为经历了那些事情后我真正意识到，没有人会替我发声。你知道的，约会交友圈里的每个人，都在把自己放在第一位。所以轮到我把自己的放在第一位了。也轮到我对自己的要求表现得强势一些了。说实话，这挺有意思的，因为我觉得我当时可能有点过头了。我现在的男朋友，我差点就没跟他去约会。这就像是我们现在常讲的一个趣事：他当时在约会当天还没确认计划。而我当时正在发短信。
my friends being like, no, a real man wouldn't treat me this way. My soulmate wouldn't treat me this way. I'm not going to go on this date. But I give him a second chance. I'm so glad that I did. And here we are now. So my experience aside, what is it that makes us lose our power in dating? I think the first reason why you may end up in a similar situation to me, kind of dating losers with people that don't treat you right, is because of repeated rejection. Being rejected by someone you like or admire, it stings on a very deep interpersonal level. A great deal of human emotion is going to come from rejection and is going to emerge in the face of real anticipated, imagined, even remembered rejection by other people. We are socially primed to experience rejection as a painful experience,
对我的朋友们说，不，真正的男人不会这样对待我。我的灵魂伴侣不会这样对待我。我才不去约会呢。但我还是给了他第二次机会。我太高兴我这么做了。我们现在就在这里。所以抛开我的经历不谈，究竟是什么让我们在约会中失去了掌控力呢？我认为你可能陷入与我相似境地的第一个原因，也就是和那些不对劲的人、不善待你的人约会，是因为反复遭受拒绝。被你喜欢或钦佩的人拒绝，会在非常深厚的人际交往层面上刺痛你。很大一部分人类情感都源于拒绝，并将在面对真实、预期、想象甚至是对其他人拒绝的回忆时显现出来。我们在社会心理上就被设定为将拒绝视为一种痛苦的经历，
almost physically painful and then as a result of that turn inwards looking for answers as to why we were the ones who were wrong we were the ones who were different we were the one who couldn't make this person happy or couldn't fit in a consequence of that is that we believe that we must be the ones who have to change or who have to adapt in order to be accepted so there was a 2000 study that found that the more rejection you experience, the more you actually do begin to cope through avoidant strategies. So this was actually a study done on academics, university academics, who were told that their papers and manuscripts had either been rejected or not. And they found in the experimental condition where, you know, certain participants were having papers rejected left, right, and
几乎是身体上的痛苦，然后作为这种经历的结果，我们会向内审视，寻找答案：为什么我们是错的，为什么我们与众不同，为什么是我们没能让这个人开心，或者没能融入其中。这种心态带来的一个后果是，为了被接纳，我们坚信自己必须是那个需要改变或适应的人。因此，有一项2000年的研究发现，你经历的拒绝越多，你实际上就越开始通过回避策略来应对。这其实是一项针对大学学者的研究，他们被告知他们的论文和手稿是否被拒绝。研究人员发现在实验条件下，某些参与者的论文左、右、
center, the more rejections they received, fake rejections, the more they received, fake rejections, the more they withdrew, the more they became quite hostile, but in general, the more they actually began to doubt themselves. Now, obviously, this was an experiment. These rejections actually had nothing to do with the quality of their work, but they ended up really believing that just because this random person told them that their paper was terrible or that they didn't deserve some kind of accolade, it must be true. And very few of them said, oh, I don't actually think you're right. I think your criticisms of me are wrong. It's so bizarre how we as humans are so quick to trust other people's approval or judgments of us, but we are so ready to dismiss or not even think about our own,
中间都被拒绝了，他们收到的拒绝越多——虚假的拒绝，他们收到的虚假拒绝越多，他们就越退缩，变得越发充满敌意，但总的来说，他们实际上越发开始自我怀疑。当然，这只是一个实验。这些拒绝实际上与他们工作的质量毫无关系，但他们最终却深信不疑，仅仅因为这个随机的人告诉他们论文很糟糕，或者他们不配得到某种荣誉，这就一定是对的。极少有人会说：“哦，其实我觉得你不对。你对我的批评是错的。”我们人类是如此急于相信别人对我们的认可或判断，而对于自己的想法，却又是如此准备随时忽视甚至压根不去思考，这真是太离奇了。
not even think about what we think. And rejection will do that to you. Another piece of research from the University of New South Wales here in Australia, also found that, you know, repeated rejection is one thing. Sometimes, for some of us, all it takes is one really profound, emotionally salient rejection to change you. So according to this doctor who ran the study, Dr. Zimmerman, if we experience a really unexpected romantic rejection early in life, this can actually be a catalyst of.
甚至不去想我们自己的想法。而拒绝就会带给你这种影响。来自澳大利亚新南威尔士大学的另一项研究也发现，反复拒绝是一回事。有时对我们中的某些人来说，只需要一次真正深刻、在情感上产生强烈影响的拒绝就能改变你。因此，根据进行这项研究的齐默尔曼博士（Dr. Zimmerman）所说，如果我们在早年经历了一次非常出乎意料的浪漫拒绝，这实际上可能会成为
for a lot of trust issues and it's very hard to understand why it's happened but it's because this experience of really committing to someone and wanting them to like you and then feeling rejected is so painful that your brain almost promises to itself for that to never happen again now if your self-worth has been depleted by a number of dates not working out a few instances are being ghosted or turned down or just even a significant one-off. You may firstly try to avoid those feelings, but then you'll begin to change your attitudes and your actions. And one way that we do that and one way that we respond to romantic rejection is that
产生很多信任问题的催化剂。这很难理解为什么会发生，但这是因为这种全心投入并希望对方喜欢你、却随后感到被拒绝的经历是如此痛苦，以至于你的大脑几乎向自己承诺，绝不再让这种事发生。现在，如果你的自我价值感已经因为几次不成功的约会、几次被无故疏远或拒绝、甚至是某次重大的单一打击而被消磨殆尽，你可能会首先试图逃避那些感受，但随后你就会开始改变自己的态度和行动。我们这样做的一种方式、也是我们对浪漫拒绝做出反应的一种方式，就是
we lower our standards and we settle. We do this because we have likely developed an actual fear of rejection at this point. So we want to prevent it from happening again. and the way that we can prevent it from happening again is either A, completely withdrawing, or B, shaping ourselves to constantly be what someone else wants, because that will ensure that no one will ever make us feel the way that we've already been made to feel. The second reason we may have lost our power in dating is because of a really unfortunate and painful experience of relationship trauma.
我们降低标准并选择将就。我们这样做是因为此时我们可能已经对拒绝产生了真实的恐惧。所以我们想要阻止它再次发生。而阻止它再次发生的途径要么是A，完全退缩；要么是B，塑造自己去不断迎合别人的需求，因为这样就能确保再也没有人会让我们感受到曾经体验过的那种痛苦。我们在约会中失去掌控力的第二个原因，是因为一段非常不幸且痛苦的关系创伤经历。
This is going to come in a lot of forms. But some examples of relationship trauma include being cheated on, even repeated instances of micro cheating, being in quite an emotionally volatile relationship where you never knew where you stood, being betrayed a traumatic breakup, just some examples. Something that many of us don't know is that relationship trauma in our late teens and our early 20s does actually have the ability to reshape our attachment style. We often tend to think that our attachment style is somewhat locked in after childhood and that the only thing that influences attachment style is our parental relationships and our attachment to them. That is not true.
这会有很多表现形式。但关系创伤的一些例子包括被背叛、甚至反复遭受微背叛（micro cheating）、身处情绪极不稳定且让你永远摸不透对方心意的关系中、遭受背叛、经历痛苦的分手，这些都只是例子。我们许多人并不知道的是，青春期晚期和20世纪初期的关系创伤，实际上确实有能力重塑我们的依恋风格。我们常常倾向于认为我们的依恋风格在童年后就基本定型了，唯一能影响依恋风格的是我们与父母的关系以及对他们的依恋。事实并非如此。
A 2017 paper titled Adult Attachment, Stress and Romantic Relationships, I actually discovered this piece of research when I was researching my book, but it found that there are three. types of negative events in adulthood that can actually rewire your attachment style. So there's negative external events. This has nothing to do with your relationship but still makes you feel unsteady. So may have been the death of a loved one or the death of a partner or an injury or a really traumatic, dangerous situation you went through with someone. Then we have negative relational events. So conflict, separation, abandonment, breakup. And then, cognitive or emotional events. So this may be that your attachment style has been rewired because you as a person have started
一篇发表于2017年、题为《成人依恋、压力与恋爱关系》的论文——我其实是在研究自己的书时发现这篇研究的——发现成年期有三种类型的负面事件实际上可以重塑你的依恋风格。首先是消极的外部事件。这与你的恋爱关系无关，但依然会让你感到心神不定。可能是一个亲爱之人的离世、伴侣的离世、一次受伤，或者你和某人一起经历的真正具创伤性、危险的情况。其次是消极的关系事件。比如冲突、分离、抛弃、分手。最后是认知或情感事件。这可能意味着你的依恋风格被重塑了，因为你作为一个人开始
experiencing heightened levels of anxiety due to some biological change, due to some cognitive change. You start seeing everything with anxiety, including your relationship. The biggest one though is the second. Relational events, specifically negative relational events. So much trust and vulnerability. goes into caring for someone and goes into loving someone. And when someone takes that trust and vulnerability and treats it like it's nothing,
由于某种生物学变化、由于某种认知变化，经历了更高水平的焦虑。你开始用焦虑的眼光看待一切，包括你的恋爱关系。不过，其中影响最大的还是第二种。关系事件，特别是消极的关系事件。照顾一个人需要倾注这么多的信任与脆弱，爱一个人也需要倾注这么多的信任与脆弱。而当有人拿着这份信任与脆弱却把它视若草芥时，
that does leave permanent damage. And it may explain why we can enter a relationship entirely secure and in an entirely healthy place only to leave it anxious or avoidant or insecure and with a whole new perspective on love. So finally, the third reason we lose our power in dating is because we begin to adopt a scarcity mindset. In other words, we let whoever it may be, the media, our married friends, our parents, we let them convince us that we are running out of time to find a quote unquote good one. The scarcity mindset, it's actually an economics term, and it refers to the belief that a resource is limited and that results in us making irrational decisions.
这就会留下永久的伤害。这或许就能解释为什么我们能带着完全安全感、处于完全健康的的状态进入一段关系，结果离开时却变得焦虑、回避或缺乏安全感，并对爱情有了全新看法。所以最后，我们在约会中失去掌控力的第三个原因，是因为我们开始采纳稀缺心态。换句话说，我们任由无论什么人——媒体、已婚的朋友、我们的父母——说服我们，让我们相信自己寻找所谓“好对象”的时间已经不多了。稀缺心态实际上是一个经济学术语，指的是这样一种信念：某种资源是有限的，这会导致我们做出不理智的决定。
It's why, say you're at the grocery store and you're trying to buy your favorite yogurt and suddenly there's only two of these yogurts left, like it's almost sold out. You only need one yogurt, but you're going to buy two because this idea of scarcity is making you make irrational decisions. It's the same reason why if someone tells you that a bag is one of a kind or exclusive, you're more likely to want to buy it because they've created scarcity within you, where if something seems less available, it actually feels more worthwhile to have. Yes, the scarcity mindset usually refers to a consumer good. It can also refer to love and why we feel
这就是为什么，假设你在杂货店里想买你最喜欢的酸奶，突然发现这种酸奶只剩两杯了，简直快卖光了。你其实只需要一杯酸奶，但你还是会买两杯，因为这种稀缺感驱使你做出不理智的决定。这也是为什么如果有人告诉你某个包是独一无二的或限量的，你会更想买它，因为他们在你心中制造了稀缺感，当某种东西看起来不那么容易获得时，拥有它的价值感反而会增加。是的，稀缺心态通常指的是消费品。但它也可以指代爱情，以及为什么我们会觉得
that a good partner is becoming a lot harder to find. So the other important part of this concept is that it can actually be artificially altered. So basically, in economics, people can make you think that something is scarce and can make you think that something is less available. And they do that as a way to make you want to buy it. There are a lot of ways that we are made to feel like a good relationship is quite scarce at the moment, whether it's dating horror stories, whether it's, you know, how dating apps are structured, whether it's all the hit pieces people are writing in magazines that it's harder for millennials to find love, etc., etc.
找到一个好伴侣正变得越来越难。因此，这个概念另一个重要部分在于，这种稀缺感实际上是可以被人为改变的。基本上，在经济学中，人们可以让你觉得某样东西很稀缺，可以让你觉得某样东西不那么容易得到。他们这样做是为了让你产生购买欲。有很多方法让我们觉得目前一段好的恋情相当稀缺，无论是约会恐怖故事、约会软件的架构设计，还是人们在杂志上写的关于千禧一代更难找到真爱等各种尖锐文章，等等。
It's all making us very, very scared. I want to remind you, people come on and off the market, the dating market, every single day. People move cities. People suddenly come back on the market and are ready to date again. People break up.
这一切都让我们感到非常非常害怕。我想提醒你们，每天都有人在进入和退出约会市场。人们搬去别的城市。人们突然重返市场并准备好再次约会。人们在分手。
There is someone perfect for you out there thinking exactly what you are thinking right now. Oh my gosh, there's no good. people left. And here you are thinking the same thing. And I think that's part of the story that you're going to tell each other one day of like, oh my God, I'd really given up hope and here you are. But in the meantime, don't let a scarcity mindset take over and cause you to miss out on meeting that person because you felt like you had to hurry up and settle down. I don't think that's, I don't think
外面肯定有一个完美适合你的人，正想着和你此刻一模一样的想法。天哪，没有好人剩下了。而你此时也正想着同样的事情。我想这正是你们将来有一天会讲给彼此听的故事的一部分，比如：“天哪，我当时真的已经放弃希望了，结果你就出现了。”但在那之前，不要让稀缺心态占据上风，并导致你因为觉得自己必须赶紧安定下来而错过了遇到那个人的机会。我认为这不，我认为
that's the healthiest decision for you right now. And I always say, you would much rather be single for another 10 years and find your person at 35 or 39 or 32 then spend the next 10 years with someone that you settled for and have to break up anyways and be back in the same spot but now just with more emotional damage so we lose our power because of rejection relationship trauma and a scarcity mindset to name the big three what are the consequences of this well we've already spoken about a few i think the biggest one is self-rengthy abandonment, abandoning what you need in a relationship, ignoring your needs just for the idea and the promise of love. This can mean that we often let others make decisions for us. We ignore
这对你来说并不是最健康的决定。我总是说，你宁愿单身个十年，然后在35岁、39岁或32岁时找到属于你的那个人，也不愿把接下来的十年浪费在和一个你将就的人在一起，最后还得分手，落得和原来一样的境地，只是身上添了更多情感创伤。所以我们失去掌控力是因为拒绝、关系创伤以及稀缺心态，这三大主要原因。这会带来什么后果呢？我们之前已经讨论过一些了。我认为最大的一点就是自我放弃，抛弃你在关系中的需求，仅仅为了爱情的构想和承诺而忽视你的需求。这意味着我们经常让别人替我们做决定。我们忽视了
what we need from a situation. We ruminate constantly about whether this other person likes us rather than whether we like ourselves or whether we even like them. And we also, we also begin to tolerate behavior that we never imagined for ourselves and we never imagined would be part of our love story. Another consequence of abandoning ourselves or lowering our standards, losing our power, is that I actually think we begin to feel, feel it in our body, feel a lot of discomfort, distress and emotional pain. When you're dating someone or when, you know, you're in the process of courting people who are treating you poorly where you feel like you have no agency, you have no control. I often find that that creates a lot of bodily tension. It creates real signs,
我们从这种处境中真正需要的是什么。我们不断纠结于这个人是否喜欢我们，而不是我们是否喜欢自己，甚至是我们是否真的喜欢他们。而且我们还开始容忍那些我们从未想过会发生在自己身上、也从未想过会成为我们爱情故事一部分的行为。自我放弃或降低标准、失去掌控力的另一个后果是，我真的认为我们开始在身体上感受到它，感受到大量的不适、痛苦和情感痛苦。当你和某人约会时，或者当你（你知道的）处于追求那些对待你很差、让你觉得自己毫无主动权和控制权的人的过程中时，
physical signs of emotional distress, like crying a lot, like feeling sore in parts of your body, feeling nauseous. There's a really fascinating paper that was published in 2014 and it attempted to map where we feel emotions in our body because typically we do feel emotions physically before we feel them consciously and mentally, we just don't realize it. And what this paper found was that when we feel discomfort, stress, anxiety, emotional tension, we tend to feel at first in our face, behind our eyes,
我经常发现这会产生大量的身体紧张感。它会产生真实的情感痛苦的生理信号，比如经常哭泣、身体某些部位感到酸痛、感到恶心。2014年发表了一篇非常迷人的论文，它试图绘制我们在身体哪个部位感受到情绪，因为通常情况下，在我们有意识和心理上感知到情绪之前，我们已经在生理上感受到了，只是我们没有意识到而已。这篇论文发现的是，当我们感到不适、压力、焦虑和情感紧张时，我们往往首先在面部、眼睛后面、
in our throat, in our stomach. When you lose your power in dating and you are dating people who make you feel terrible, you are going to feel terrible. Your body is going to let you know that it's not happy with these, emotional circumstances. I remember a friend telling me how she went through this period of dating the wrong person and she felt nauseous and ill the entire time. She went to the doctor, she thought she may have an ulcer, she thought it was something serious, maybe like a really bad bacteria. When she
在喉咙里、在胃里感受到。当你在约会中失去掌控力，并且在和那些让你感觉糟糕的人约会时，你就会感觉很糟糕。你的身体会让你知道，它对这种情感处境很不满意。我记得一个朋友告诉我，她曾经历过一段和错误的人约会的时期，她整个过程中都感到恶心和不舒服。她去看医生，以为自己得了溃疡，以为是什么严重的问题，比如某种非常有害的细菌。当她
left the relationship, that illness cleared within weeks. And I know that sounds, quite, I don't know, serendipitous or convenient or like a coincidence. I promise you it's not. The emotional and social interactions that you're having, specifically ones that feel so intimate and vulnerable, if they are not right, if they don't sit right with you mentally, they're not going to sit right with you physically. And I think love and dating is not something that we can play games with, especially if you are someone who is rather sensitive and rather romantic because it does influence you. It influences your mind. It influences your body. It influences your soul. Okay. So now to the juicy bit, what can we do about it? We're going to take a short break, but when we return,
离开那段关系后，那种病症在几周内就消失了。我知道这听起来相当……我不知道，像是一种机缘巧合、很凑巧或者是个巧合。我向你保证，绝对不是。你所经历的情感和社交互动，特别是那些感觉如此亲密和脆弱的互动，如果它们不对劲，如果它们在精神上让你感觉不对劲，那么它们在身体上也绝对不会让你感觉舒服。我认为爱情和约会不是我们可以随便开玩笑的事情，特别是如果你是一个比较敏感、比较浪漫的人，因为它确实会影响你。它会影响你的精神。它会影响你的身体。它会影响你的灵魂。好了。接下来是最精彩的部分，我们该怎么做呢？我们先休息一下，但当我们回来时，
I've got my five biggest tips for you today. So stay tuned. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我今天将分享我最重要的五个建议，所以请继续收听。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the reasons. result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do little Kim. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS. on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊一整天快克，但对，对，字面意思。但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论爱滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事物的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个事物。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're a friend? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们总是在记分牌上盯着胜负。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？还是说你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是这样。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines），在我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。
Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soles, correct?
搜索《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探的力量才破解了这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利和迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any matter. should live by.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何有品位的人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，永远不要惹农家女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》（The Girlfriends）的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is going to sound so cliche and I'm sorry for it in advance, but it's not you, it's just dating. It's just the way that dating is working at the moment. it's a battlefield where the way we have been socialized to date in the 21st century and to treat others especially these days is in a very transactional way, a very flippant way and also in a way that I think essentially assumes that someone better is always going to come along. And it means that you have to have stronger boundaries and be a lot more intentional about what you want
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这听起来可能非常老套，我提前为此道歉，但这不是你的问题，这就是约会本身的问题。这只是目前约会运作的方式，它是一个战场，我们在21世纪被社会化去约会的方式以及对待他人的方式，尤其是这些天，以一种非常功利的方式，一种非常轻率的方式，而且我也认为，这种方式基本上假设总会有一个更好的人出现。这意味着你必须建立更强的界限，并且对你想要的
from a relationship. If this doesn't come naturally to you, it didn't come naturally to me. If it's been scared out of you, don't worry, I'm going to give you the formula for how to really reapply agency and control when it comes to your dating experiences. Now, some of these
从一段关系中得到的东西更有意识。如果这对你来说不是天生的，对我来说也不是天生的。如果它已经被吓跑了，别担心，我将为你提供一套方法，教你如何在约会经历中真正重新掌握自主权和控制权。现在，其中一些
may sound kind of obvious. You may have heard them before, but I think the reason I'm saying them again is because they are very, very important. So even if they're not new to you, I do hope that you still absorb them in the same way. Let's start with my first tip. My first tip is that you need to take a dating detox.
听起来可能有点显而易见。你可能以前听过，但我认为我再次提起它们的原因是它们非常非常重要。所以即使对你来说不是新鲜事，我仍然希望你能以同样的方式吸收它们。让我们从我的第一个建议开始。我的第一个建议是，你需要进行一次约会排毒。
You need to take a full big step back from dating before you can dive in again. Half the reason I finally start cutting corners with dating or giving up control is because we are simply emotionally exhausted and our ability to uphold our values has been slowly whittled away over time. If you are feeling more tired than excited to go on dates, if you are dragging yourself to dates, just wanting to get it over with, hoping to find someone good enough,
在再次投入之前，你需要从约会中彻底退后一大步。我最终开始在约会中走捷径或放弃控制的一半原因，是因为我们在情感上精疲力竭，我们维护价值观的能力随着时间慢慢被侵蚀。如果你去约会感到疲惫多于兴奋，如果你是拖着自己去约会，只是想快点结束，希望能找到一个差不多够好的人，
so you don't have to be single anymore, pause and just stop dating altogether because this is a very straight and narrow path to settling. You're probably experiencing dating burnout. And it's very similar to career or workplace or emotional burnout. And it's very similar in the sense that it's going to get progressively worse and worse until you do a full reset. Now something I see with people who are experiencing dating burnout is that they'll take a step back for like a couple of weeks. That doesn't give them the chance to fully fill up their cup and to restore all their depleted emotional resources.
这样你就不用再单身了，暂停一下，彻底停止约会，因为这是一条通往将就的笔直狭窄的道路。你可能正在经历约会倦怠。这与职业、工作场所或情感倦怠非常相似。它的相似之处在于，它会逐渐变得越来越糟，直到你进行一次彻底的重置。现在我看到经历约会倦怠的人的一个现象是，他们会退后几步大约几周。这并没有给他们机会彻底充满电并恢复他们所有消耗的情感资源。
I think you need six months minimum to get back to yourself post-dating burnout before you are ready to date again. And I'm going to give this my most profound big personal endorsement ever. I actually did do a six-month dating detox before I met my partner Tom. And I'm not saying that it magically made the love of my life appear. What I am saying is that I was able to really see clearly. when he showed up and I was able to kind of push through all the garbage and the chaos of other people who weren't meant for me but if I hadn't done a dating detox I would have overly invested in them. My second tip, you need to have a list of non-negotiables.
我认为在经历约会倦怠后，你至少需要六个月的时间来找回自己，然后才能准备好再次约会。我要给出我至今为止最深刻的个人背书。在我遇到我的伴侣汤姆之前，我确实进行了一次为期六个月的约会排毒。我并不是说这神奇地让我的生命之爱出现了。我想说的是，当他出现时，我能够真正看清，并且我能够穿过那些不属于我的人的垃圾和混乱，但如果我没有进行约会排毒，我会过度投入到他们身上。我的第二个建议，你需要有一份不可妥协的清单。
This list is going to be your best friend and it will allow you to shift from seeking validation to seeking self-approval. it will allow you to stop asking yourself, oh, do they like me? Are they enjoying my company? Do they want to go on a second date with me? To, do I like them? Did I have fun on that date? Is this someone I could see a future with?
这份清单将成为你最好的朋友，它将使你从寻求认可转向寻求自我认可。它将让你不再问自己，“噢，他们喜欢我吗？他们喜欢我的陪伴吗？他们想和我进行第二次约会吗？”，而是变成，“我喜欢他们吗？我在那次约会中玩得开心吗？这真的是一个我能看到未来的人吗？”
I think what it really does is it recenters something that we've lost along the way. What it recenters is our own opinion at the center of our life. This really is the judgment and the opinion that matters the most. Be as selfish as you want. I don't think we hear that a lot in life. I think there are very few instances where society is okay with telling us to be selfish, but I'm going to tell it to you right now. Be selfish and assume that everyone else is dating with their own best interests at heart until they prove that they can be a good partner, until they prove that they are worthy of compromise or of selflessness, I think you need to keep the focus squarely
我认为它真正做到的是，重新把我们一路上失去的东西放在中心。它重新将我们自己的意见置于我们生活的中心。这确实是最重要的判断和意见。你想多自私就多自私。我认为我们在生活中很少听到这样的话。我认为社会很少有赞成告诉我们要自私的时刻，但我现在就要告诉你。自私一点，并假设其他每个人约会时都怀着他们自己最好的利益，直到他们证明自己可以成为一个好伴侣，直到他们证明自己值得妥协或无私，我认为你需要把注意力完全集中在
on you and what you want. And this is where this list of non-negotiables becomes really, really important. Because if we just say, oh yeah, I'm not going to compromise and we don't have a list or we don't have some idea of what we don't want to compromise on, essentially we just end up doing it anyways. It's like, imagine going to a financial planner and saying, I want to be rich, but you don't know what you want to spend that money on and you don't know what you currently spend your money on and you don't know what your essential financial needs are, your financial planner is going to sit there and say, so what exactly do you want for me? Like, you're not going to be able to achieve what you want in money, in life, in relationships without already having a vision. I'm going to give you actually
你身上以及你想要什么上。这就是这份不可妥协的清单变得非常非常重要的地方。因为如果我们只是说，“噢，是的，我不会妥协”，而我们没有清单，或者我们对不想妥协的事情没有一些概念，本质上我们最终还是会妥协。这就像，想象一下去见一个财务规划师，然后说：“我想变得富有，但你不知道你想把钱花在什么上，你不知道你目前把钱花在了什么上，你也不知道你的基本财务需求是什么，”你的财务规划师会坐在那里对你说：“那你到底想从我这里得到什么？”就像，如果你没有一个愿景，你就无法在金钱、生活、关系中实现你想要的东西。我其实要给你
my non-negotiable list. I pulled this out of my notes app archives. I used to bring up this list after every single first date or sometimes second date that I'd had with someone, just to be very clear with myself, is this person matching my requirements or am I being delusional? So this was my list. They must be someone looking for monogamy. They must be someone who I respect and admire. They must have a career, job or hobby that they're passionate about. They must have time for me.
我的不可妥协清单。这是我从我的备忘录应用档案里翻出来的。我过去在与某人进行每一次约会后，或者有时是第二次约会后，都会拿出这份清单，只是为了让自己非常清楚：这个人符合我的要求吗？还是我在自欺欺人？所以这就是我的清单。他们必须是一个正在寻找一夫一妻制的人。他们必须是我尊重和钦佩的人。他们必须有他们热爱的职业、工作或爱好。他们必须有时间陪我。
They must openly communicate with me. They must want to live overseas and they must want to have a family one day. These were all things I knew I needed to feel emotionally secure and to have a future with someone. But they were also things that I knew that if I overlooked in the present, they would be relationship ending in the future. And I saw dating as something I couldn't just have exclusively have fun with anymore. I was still having fun, but I knew that I was someone who got carried away very, very easily. I got attached very, very easily.
他们必须对我坦诚沟通。他们必须想去海外生活，而且他们必须希望有一天能有一个家庭。这些都是我知道自己需要的东西，以在情感上感到安全并与某人共创未来。但这也是我知道如果在当下忽视它们，它们将在未来成为毁灭关系的事情。我将约会视为一种我不能再仅仅单方面享受乐趣的事情。我仍然在享受乐趣，但我知道我是一个非常非常容易被带跑的人。我非常非常容易产生依恋。
This was my insurance. You know, whose advice was going to take out of anyone's? I was probably going to take my own. And so this was a way to say, hey, your past self thought this was important. Why are you neglecting it now? So make a list. It should have at least five things on your list.
这是我的保险。你知道，如果要听取任何人的建议，我会听取谁的？我大概会听取我自己的。所以这是一种表达方式，嘿，过去的你认为这很重要。你现在为什么在忽视它？所以列个清单。你的清单上至少应该有五件事。
If you can't think of five, I think you need to be more picky because there are most certainly five things that you can think of that would make a relationship perhaps not work for you. So make sure you know what they are, you're clear about it, you reflect on past experiences, and you use your list. My third tip for reclaiming your power in dating
如果你想不出五件，我认为你需要更挑剔，因为肯定有五件事你可以想到，这些事情可能会让一段关系对你不适用。所以确保你知道它们是什么，你对它们很清楚，你反思过去的经验，并使用你的清单。我在约会中夺回自主权的第三个建议
is to stop playing games, stop playing games and set the example for how you want to be treated. Dating is hard enough. You don't need to make it any more confusing for yourself. The kind of games, talking about include things like not texting them back for the same amount of time that they didn't text you. I'm guilty of doing that once or twice. Pretending not to be interested at parties or when you see them, making them jealous deliberately, ignoring them or expecting them to read your mind
就是停止玩游戏，停止玩游戏，并为你想被对待的方式树立榜样。约会已经够难了。你不需要让自己感到更困惑。我所说的游戏包括诸如不按照他们不回你信息的相同时间回复他们。我有过一两次这样的罪恶感。在聚会上或当你看到他们时假装不感兴趣，故意让他们嫉妒，忽视他们或者期望他们能读懂你的心思
or testing them without them knowing it. All of this just puts up further barriers between you and the other person. In all honesty, I think that the games we play in the early stages of dating, they are a defense mechanism. I think it's a way of feeling more in control, or of keeping people at a distance because of previous times that you have been hurt or you have been let down. And so pretending not to be interested keeps this nice buffer between you and them where you can pretend to yourself as well. Or ignoring them allows you to ignore the fact that you are actually really invested in them as a person. And you do really like them. And that's okay even if it doesn't work out. It's really just a healthy sign that you know what you want and that you are brave enough to
或者在他们不知情的情况下测试他们。所有这些只会增加你和另说之间更多的障碍。老实说，我认为我们在约会初期玩的游戏是一种防御机制。我认为这是一种感觉更有控制力的方式，或者由于你以前受过伤或失望过而与他人保持距离的方式。所以假装不感兴趣在你和他们之间保持了一个很好的缓冲，你也可以对自己假装。或者忽视他们能让你忽视这样一个事实：你实际上真的作为一个个体投入了他们。你确实真的很喜欢他们。即使没有成功也没关系。这其实是一个健康的信号，表明你知道自己想要什么，并且你有足够的勇气去
feel deeply about someone else that I think is, I just think that's a good sign for future relationship health. So don't wait to text them. Don't pretend you're not interested. Show up the way that you would want someone else to show up for you without the games. I think in the same vein if someone is playing games with you, I want you to remember that a mixed signal is still a signal. If they are making you feel anxious or uncomfortable, if they are causing you to doubt yourself, I need you to detach and pull all of your energy back. I need you to show them very clearly this kind of behavior will not get my attention and it will not get my respect and it most certainly will not get me. And honestly, I actually don't think it's a bad thing to just say that to someone, to just say,
对别人产生深厚的情感，我认为这，我只是认为这是未来关系健康的良好信号。所以不要等着回信息。不要假装你不感兴趣。以你希望别人对待你的方式出现，不要玩游戏。我认为同样地，如果有人在跟你玩游戏，我希望你记住，模棱两可的信号依然是信号。如果他们让你感到焦虑或不舒服，如果他们让你怀疑自己，我需要你抽离并收回你所有的能量。我需要非常清楚地向他们表明，这种行为不会引起我的注意，也不会赢得我的尊重，最重要的是，它不会赢得我。说实话，我觉得直接对某人说出来并不是一件坏事，只需说：
I don't like these games. And I'll be honest when I met my partner, when I met my boyfriend Tom, he's a lawyer. I don't think I've said that before, but he's a lawyer. And so he's very, very busy. And when we first started dating, like we would text a lot and I wouldn't hear from him for like, you know, four hours and I'd be like, oh my God, he's playing games. And so I said to him, I was like, hey, I need you to text me back quicker because this makes me feel really insecure and it makes me feel like, you're not interested. So if you're playing games with this, like, I'm not interested in it.
我不喜欢这些游戏。老实说，当我遇到我的伴侣时，当我遇到我的男朋友汤姆时，他是一名律师。我想我以前没说过这个，但他是一名律师。所以他非常非常忙。当我们刚开始约会时，我们经常发信息，然后我会几个小时听不到他的消息，我会想，天哪，他在玩游戏。所以我对他说，我说，嘿，我需要你更快地回复信息，因为这让我感到非常不安全，让我觉得你对我不感兴趣。所以如果你在玩这个游戏，我对此不感兴趣。
And if it's something else that I need to understand about your communication style, let me know. And that's how I found out that my boyfriend actually has a really healthy relationship with his phone. And I perhaps do not. But yes, please prioritize. self-respect over temporary feelings. If someone is disrespecting you, playing games, or they don't align with your standards, walk away. I don't think your self-worth is up for negotiation. The way they treat you in the beginning is the way they're going to treat you for the
如果这是我需要了解的关于你的沟通风格的其他事情，请告诉我。这就是我发现我的男朋友其实和他的手机有着非常健康的联系的方式。而我可能没有。但是，是的，请优先考虑自尊，而不是暂时的感受。如果有人不尊重你，玩游戏，或者他们不符合你的标准，那就离开。我认为你的自我价值是不容谈判的。他们在开始时对待你的方式就是他们将如何对待你
entire relationship. It's not going to get any better than the early days when they're trying to court you. Please remember that. If you're someone who does still find that they put the rose-colored glasses on, This is my litmus test. This is the question I would ask myself. Is this the story that I would tell about my soulmate? If in the future we had children and our children asked about how we first met and how we first started dating,
整个关系的方式。这不会比他们在试图追求你时的早期更好。请记住这一点。如果你是一个仍然发现自己戴着玫瑰色眼镜的人，这是我的试金石。这是我会问自己的问题：这是我会讲的关于我的灵魂伴侣的故事吗？如果将来我们有了孩子，我们的孩子问起我们是如何第一次见面以及我们是如何开始约会的，
would I want to tell them the truth about this story? Because if someone is not giving you a good story or a good narrative or is not treating you in a way that you would be happy to tell your children or your parents, or your parents or your friends how they were treating you. No, they're not the one. Okay, so my fourth tip is actually to do with the first date and how to really make sure that you are stepping into the room, the bar, wherever you are meeting this person, feeling confident, feeling like you can advocate for what you want, feeling like you have the power. So before I would go on first dates, I used to have three or four affirmations that I would
我愿意把这个故事的真相告诉他们吗？因为如果一个人没有给你一个好的故事或一个好的叙述，或者没有以一种你乐意告诉你的孩子、你的父母，或者你的父母或你的朋友他们是如何对待你的方式对待你。不，他们不是那个人。好的，所以我的第四个建议实际上与第一次约会有关，以及如何真正确保你走进房间、酒吧，无论你在哪里与这个人见面，都感到自信，觉得你可以为自己想要的东西发声，觉得你拥有力量。所以在去第一次约会之前，我过去常常有三到四句肯定的话，我
always tell myself. I would get ready. I would listen to a specific playlist that I had made filled with like music that was over 100 beats per minute. So like high energy, exciting. And then before I would leave, I would repeat these four affirmations, three to four affirmations to myself in the mirror. The first one, I already have everything I need in life. Love is just a bonus. That was my favorite. The second, I am enigmatic. The third, I am masterful. The fourth, I'm confident. The words that you speak to yourself become reality.
总是告诉自己。我会做好准备。我会听一个我制作的特定播放列表，里面装满了每分钟超过100拍的音乐。所以就像高能量、令人兴奋的。然后在我离开之前，我会对着镜子对自己重复这四句肯定的话，三到四句肯定的话。第一句，我生活中已经拥有我需要的一切。爱只是一个额外的好处。那是我的最爱。第二，我是神秘的。第三，我是大师级的。第四，我很自信。你对自己说的话会变成现实。
We see that time and time again in studies and research on positive self-talk. You can let yourself and your sense of self be dictated by external judgments and other people's opinions, or you can take all of that information and say, None of this is as important as what I have to say about myself, the judgments I have of myself, how well I feel in my own body. Right before I would go into the date, like I had done my positive self-talk, I had done my music, I had done all these little small things that made me feel like I was going to have fun. I would do this physical exercise where I would stand outside and I would, right before I would go in, put my chest up, shoulders back and I would just like shake everything out. I do this like huge smile and I would just imagine all this energy lifting from my toes all the way to my head. And I would just be ready to have a fun time.
我们在关于积极自我对话的研究中一次又一次地看到这一点。你可以让自己和你的自我感被外部判断和别人的意见所左右，或者你可以接受所有这些信息并说：所有这些都不如我对自己的评价、我对自己的判断、我在自己的身体里感觉多好那么重要。就在我进入约会之前，就像我已经进行了积极的自我对话，我听了音乐，我做了所有这些小事情，让我觉得自己会玩得很开心。我会做这个身体锻炼，我会在外面站着，就在我进去之前，挺起胸膛，双肩向后，我就会把一切都甩掉。我露出一个大大的笑容，我就会想象所有的能量从我的脚趾一直升到我的头部。我就会准备好玩得开心。
And I would go in being like, this could be the worst date I ever go on, but at least it's going to be a good story. And at least there is nothing that this person can say or do that is going to make me feel bad about myself because I've already kind of put on this emotional armor. I used to call this like the high value person mindset. that. Basically, I was doing everything in my power to convince myself first and foremost that I was valuable. I was deserving of love, respect, effort, that I was magnetic. I needed to make sure I believed that about me before I was trying to convince someone else. Often because if you really do believe that about yourself, someone else is going to immediately feel drawn to you. As humans, we love when other people, when we can see other people respect themselves and when they are
我进去的时候会想：这可能是我去过的最糟糕的约会，但至少它会是一个好故事。而且这个人没有什么可说或做能让我对自己的感觉变差，因为我已经穿上了这件情感盔甲。我过去称之为高价值者的心态。那个。基本上，我正在尽我所能说服自己，首先也是最重要的是我是有价值的。我值得被爱、被尊重、被付出，我是有磁性的。在我试图说服别人之前，我需要确保自己相信这一点。通常是因为如果你真的那样相信自己，别人会立刻被你吸引。作为人类，当其他人、当我们看到其他人尊重自己并且他们是
confident and when they know that they're the shit. So my final tip for reclaiming your power in dating is to reframe rejection as filtering. Research on rejection sensitivity shows that we obviously personalise rejection and we immediately assume that it's always coming down to something about us rather than about someone else's preferences. This is not a you problem. If someone doesn't like you, I need you to understand that it is their way of doing exactly what I'm asking you to do, which is advocate for yourself. And the thing is, if they know that you are not the right match for them,
自信的，并且他们知道自己很棒时，我们会感到高兴。所以我夺回约会力量的最后一个建议是将拒绝重新定义为筛选。关于拒绝敏感性的研究表明，我们显然将拒绝个性化，并立即假设这总是归结为我们自己的某些东西，而不是别人的偏好。这不是你的问题。如果有人不喜欢你，我需要你明白，这是他们做我要求你做的事情的方式，那就是为自己发声。关键是，如果他们知道你不是他们的合适伴侣，
it's actually a real gift that they have made that clear early on. Instead of convincing you and trying to convince themselves that this could work, this is all just a form of filtering. Rejection is a way of weeding out incompatible partners before you invest too much, too soon, too early. And the fact that someone else has done it for you is great, because eventually you would have found some reason to reject them and you may have felt pretty awful about it. They've saved you the pain. They've saved you the stress.
他们在早期就把它说清楚，这其实是一个真正的礼物。与其让你试图说服自己这行得通，这其实只是一种筛选的形式。拒绝是在你投入太多、太快、太早之前，剔除不兼容伴侣的一种方式。而且别人为你做了这件事太棒了，因为最终你会找到某种理由拒绝他们，你可能会对此感到非常糟糕。他们为你省去了痛苦。他们为你省去了压力。
They've also saved you the cognitive and mental effort of having to figure that out for them. The right person is going to come along and all of those rejections are going to feel worth it. And I just want you to be someone that your soulmate would fall in love with. You know, I know this sounds bizarre, but when I, went through that really terrible period, I remember saying to myself, I just don't think my soulmate would fall in love with me right now because I have no love for myself and because I'm not, I wouldn't, I wouldn't be in this situation ready to see them for who they are. They could, anyone could give me the smallest amount of interests and I would confuse them as a soulmate. So I'm not actually able to
他们还为你省去了不得不为他们弄清楚这一点的认知和精神努力。对的人会出现，所有那些拒绝都会让人觉得是值得的。我只是希望你能成为一个让你的灵魂伴侣坠入爱河的人。你知道，我知道这听起来很奇怪，但当我经历那段非常糟糕的时期时，我记得对自己说，我只是觉得我的灵魂伴侣现在不会爱上我，因为我对没有爱自己，因为我不是，我不会，我不会在这个阶段准备好看到他们的本色。任何人都可以给我一点点的兴趣，我就会把他们误认为是灵魂伴侣。所以我其实无法
delineate or tell. And most importantly, they could show me all the love and the way. world and at some level I would crave it but at another level I would think I didn't deserve it. So seriously, the focus has to be on you at every single stage until this person proves them to prove themselves to be a partner. Like you will find so much more success in dating when you make it a completely selfish activity. When you focus on yourself and when you realize once again, you already have everything you need in life. This is just a bonus. All right.
辨别或分辨。最重要的是，他们可以把世界上所有的爱和方式展现给我，在某种程度上我会渴望它，但在另一个程度上我会认为我不配拥有它。所以说真的，在每一个阶段，焦点都必须放在你身上，直到这个人证明自己是一个伴侣。就像当你把约会变成一个完全自私的活动时，你会发现约会取得了更大的成功。当你专注于自己，当你再次意识到你已经拥有生活中需要的一切。这只是一个额外的好处。好了。
We're going to take another little short break before we come back with our listener questions and our listener dilemmas around reclaiming power in dating. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在我们带着听众的问题和关于在约会中夺回力量的听众困境回来之前，我们将进行另一个简短的休息。所以请留在我们身边。百分之二。那是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of, mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我的播客《2%》中，我分解了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《2%》。即 TWO%，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金·卡戴珊有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时代，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线贯穿其中。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。收听 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了表彰心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得够多了。因为人们总是在记分牌上盯着胜负。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
绝对是这样。这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines），在我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg O'espian and Michael Marantini.
你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探的力量才破解了这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·奥斯皮安（Greg Oespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹农家女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》（The Girlfriends）的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他
deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So question one from a listener, I get attached way too quickly, but I like that I love people deeply. How do I balance those? I want to firstly say I actually don't think that it's a bad thing to get attached too quickly. I know it can like feel kind of painful for us, but if the reason you don't like that you get attached too quickly is because other people shame you for it or because you feel like people get scared off, I don't think they're the one. I don't think that they're the one if you put everything on the table and they go, oh, that's awkward. So the shame around getting attached too quickly, I'll never understand. What I do understand is the
应得的。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartradio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。所以来自听众的第一个问题：我太快产生依恋了，但我喜欢我能深深地爱别人。我该如何平衡这些？我首先想说，我其实不认为太快产生依恋是一件坏事。我知道这可能会让我们感到有点痛苦，但如果你不喜欢自己太快产生依恋的原因是因为别人因此羞辱你，或者因为你觉得人们被吓跑了，我认为他们不是那个人。如果你把一切都摆在桌面上，而他们说，“噢，这太尴尬了”，我不认为他们是那个人。所以我永远不会理解围绕太快产生依恋的羞辱。我理解的是
difficulty that comes with seeing people for their potential and not for what they're actually going to give you or for their actions or for who they are. So I would say for the first month, if you get attached too quickly, just roll back the emotional investment. So you're not completely cutting them off. I've often had this problem in the past where I know I can get attached really, really quickly. So I kind of deny myself any access to that person thinking that it's going to stop things. No, what we want is a balanced access. So limit how much you see them. Don't try and rush the timeline. In fact, create milestones for you now that you have to have to stick to. So basically create like a calendar for yourself that, you know, this person isn't allowed
看到人的潜力而不是他们实际会给你的东西、他们的行动或他们是谁所带来的困难。所以我想说，在前一个月里，如果你太快产生依恋，只需放缓情感投入。这样你就不会完全切断与他们的联系。我过去经常遇到这个问题，我知道我可以非常非常快地依恋。所以我有点拒绝自己接触那个人的任何途径，认为这会阻止事情发生。不，我们想要的是平衡的接触。所以限制你见他们的频率。不要试图赶时间线。事实上，现在就为你自己创造必须遵守的里程碑。基本上为自己创建一个日历，你知道，这个人在
to meet your friends before week six. No overnight stays before. week four. No weekend trips before week eight. Don't meet the parents before month three. Basically, despite everything that you want to do, I want you to commit to these previous limits that you have put on any relationship that you are in such that you don't end up speeding down this road and it ends up being a dead end street and you crash at the end and you feel you know, a bit embarrassed for having introduced them to family or having made such an investment of time and energy in them before they prove themselves to you. So spend as much time as you can getting to know them before you progress to that next stage of a relationship. All right. So
第六周之前不允许见你的朋友。第四周之前不允许过夜。第八周之前不允许进行周末旅行。第三个月之前不要见父母。基本上，尽管你想做什么，我希望你承诺遵守这些你之前对你所处的任何关系设定的限制，这样你最终就不会在这条路上加速行驶，而它最终是一条死胡同，你在最后撞车，并且你觉得（你知道的）在向家人介绍他们或在他们向你证明自己之前对他们投入了大量的时间和精力而感到有点尴尬。所以在你进入关系的下一个阶段之前，花尽可能多的时间去了解他们。好吧，所以
question number two, should you hold off on sex to reclaim your power? This is an interesting one because I feel like this idea of holding off sex kind of comes from like a purity culture perspective, but I do also think that sometimes we use sex as a way to like make someone like us a little bit too soon. When I was single, I found that when you slept with someone didn't really matter because if they were going to respect you, they would regardless of when you chose to be intimate. If you slept with them on the first date versus the 10th date, if that person was real and if they really liked you, it wouldn't scare them off. Also, they were involved as well.
第二个问题，为了夺回你的力量，你应该暂缓发生性关系吗？这是一个有趣的问题，因为我觉得这种暂缓性关系的观念有点来自纯洁文化的视角，但我也确实认为有时我们把性作为一种让某人过早喜欢我们的方式。当我单身时，我发现你什么时候和别人上床其实并不重要，因为如果他们要尊重你，无论你选择什么时候发生亲密关系，他们都会尊重你。如果你在第一次约会还是第十次约会时与他们上床，如果那个人是真心的，如果他们真的很喜欢你，这不会吓跑他们。而且他们也参与其中。
You know, it's not like they're thinking you're giving it up too early and that's a sign that like you're this impure person or like that you're loose because they are equally doing it. So that logic like never really made sense for me. For me, I think reclaiming my power was deciding that if I wanted to have sex on the first day, that was fine. if I wanted to have sex on the 20th date, that was also fine. My power came from deciding for myself. My power came from not being rushed into it and making sure that I examined my intentions
你知道，这不像他们认为你太早交出去了，这是一个你是这种不纯洁的人或者你很随便的信号，因为他们同样在这样做。所以这种逻辑从来没有真正对我起作用。对我来说，我认为夺回我的力量是决定如果我想在第一次约会上发生性关系，那是可以的。如果我想在第二十次约会上发生性关系，那也是可以的。我的力量来自于为自己做决定。我的力量来自于没有被催促进入其中，并确保我审视了自己的动机
so that the only reason I was doing it wasn't just to, you know, keep them for a little bit longer because I thought that's what they wanted for me. I just think, properly evaluate what tone you want to set, what you're after, and whether you feel like emotionally prepared for that vulnerability, whether you would be okay with sleeping with them and not wanting anything serious, whether you feel like you need to have sex with them just for them to like you. Like if that's your only reason, definitely don't have sex with them. But if it feels like a natural progression of the relationship and if you want to do it, you should totally, totally do it. I think again, it comes back to playing games.
这样我做这件事的唯一原因不仅仅是（你知道的）多留他们一会儿，因为我认为那是他们对我的期望。我只是认为，正确评估你想定下什么基调，你追求什么，以及你是否觉得自己在情感上为这种脆弱做好了准备，你是否能够接受与他们上床却不想要任何严肃的事情，你是否觉得你需要与他们发生性关系才能让他们喜欢你。就像如果那是你唯一的理由，绝对不要和他们发生性关系。但如果这感觉像是关系的自然进展并且你想这么做，你完全、完全应该这么做。我认为这又回到了玩游戏的问题上。
If someone isn't going to respect you or isn't going to make you feel in control or you're not going to feel powerful if you have sex with them, don't do it. But yes, I don't think that, I don't know, I don't want to say it doesn't really matter because it does matter, but I think that if it's going to change someone's opinion of you, then they're probably not the right person. All right, question number three, how to put yourself out there when you've never been in a relationship before? This is actually a question I get quite a lot. I think there are a lot more late bloomers in our 20s and in this decade than we imagine there is a huge focus on dating and sex and having these romantic experiences as like a
如果有人不尊重你，或者不会让你感到有控制力，或者如果你和他们发生性关系不会让你觉得有力量，那就不要做。但是，是的，我不认为，我不知道，我不想说这真的不重要，因为它确实重要，但我认为如果这会改变别人对你的看法，那么他们可能不是合适的人。好吧，第三个问题，当从来没有过恋爱经历时，如何展现自己？这其实是我经常被问到的一个问题。我认为在我们的20多岁和这个十年里，有很多大器晚成的人，比我们想象的要多，人们非常关注约会、性以及将这些浪漫体验作为一种
ride of passage if you're not quite there yet honestly i'm excited for you i'm really am quite excited for you because there are so much really amazing stuff to come and the experience of falling in love for the first time and having your first boyfriend or girlfriend or partner like it is actually it's just a really fun experience so don't feel like you've fallen behind feel like you've fallen behind feel like there is just so much opportunity ahead of you. I wish sometimes that I could go back and experience falling in love again for the first time all over again because it is so beautiful. But in terms of dealing with the insecurity of going out there and feeling like, oh my God, everyone, like I've never dated before. This is a new thing. Shift your mindset to think of it
成人礼，如果你还没到那一步，老实说，我为你感到兴奋，我真的为你感到兴奋，因为未来有太多非常棒的事情，坠入爱河的体验以及拥有你的第一个男朋友、女朋友或伴侣——这其实只是一次非常有趣的体验，所以不要觉得自己落后了，觉得你落后了，觉得前面有那么多的机会。我有时希望我能回到过去，重新体验第一次坠入爱河的感觉，因为它太美妙了。但在处理走出去的不安全感时，觉得自己好像，“天哪，每个人，我从来没有约过会。这是一件新鲜事。”转变你的心态去思考它
like an experiment and it makes it feel less serious. So commit to like a three month experiment of asking people out, being forward, getting on the app, getting on the apps, making the first move, asking friends to set you up and just go on as many dates as you can. Whether it's amazing, terrible, awful, it's all data. It's all research. Each experience is an important one, even if it's bad, because it's all about getting comfortable with being visible and being seen and building up those dating skills. Because it really is such a skill to be able to talk to someone that you don't know and find out the information that you want to know and it is a real skill to be vulnerable and it is a real skill to have confidence
就像是一场实验，这让你觉得没那么沉重。所以，不妨承诺进行一个为期三个月的实验：主动约人、表现得大方一点、下载交友软件、使用这些软件、迈出第一步、让朋友帮你牵线搭桥，尽可能多地去约会。不管过程是精彩、糟糕还是可怕，这全部都是数据，全都是研究。每一次经历都很重要，哪怕是糟糕的经历，因为这一切的重点在于习惯如何展现自我、如何被看见，以及提升你的约会技巧。因为能够和素不相识的人聊天、打探你想了解的信息，这确实是一项了不起的技能；能够展露脆弱是一种真正的技能；在这些情况下拥有自信和笃定也是一种真正的技能，
in these situations and to be self-assured so I think you just need to move past firstly that mental barrier and then the social barrier and just get more experience up oh I'm actually just so excited for people who are in this situation I feel like not being in a relationship feels like a burden especially if you're at a certain age but actually it's kind of a blessing because you get to be more mature when you step into your first relationship. And you've saved, like, such a beautiful thing to come a little bit later so you have more time to really savour it. So I don't want to be, like, toxic positivity on you.
所以我认为你只需要跨越心理障碍，然后是社交障碍，积累更多经验。哦，实际上我真为处于这种处境的人感到兴奋，我觉得单身感觉像是一种负担，特别是当你到了某个特定年龄时，但实际上这算是一种祝福，因为当你迈入第一段感情时，你会变得更加成熟。而且你留下了这么美好的东西，让它稍微晚一点到来，这样你就有更多时间去细细品味。所以我不想对你进行所谓的“有毒的正能量”输出。
I do just want you to see, like, the grass has grown a perspective, you know, as someone who's been in quite a few relationships, who started dating really early. Like, sometimes I do look at the experiences of people who have waited a bit longer and have just been like, wow, I'm really excited for you and it's quite a magical time. All right. Fourth and final question for today, how to come back from a horrible date that you feel completely defeated by? One word and one word only, it's humor. It's humor. Laugh about it with your friends. Treat it like a good story. Even write like a funny story about it in your notes app, like almost in the sense of this is a story that could go in like your biography or whatever. And just remember that we've
我只是想让你看到“换个角度看风景”的视角。你知道，作为一个有过不少恋爱经历、很早就开始约会的人，有时我看着那些稍微晚一点开始约会的人的经历，就会觉得：哇，我真的为你感到高兴，这是一段相当神奇的时光。好吧，今天的第四个也是最后一个问题：如何从一场让你感到彻底挫败的糟糕约会中恢复过来？一个词，而且只能是一个词：幽默。就是幽默。和朋友们一起拿它当笑话讲，把它当成一个好故事。甚至可以在你的便签应用里把这段经历写成一个搞笑的故事，就好像这个故事可以写进你的自传里一样。只要记住，我们
all been there. These are the stories that I think really exhaust us, right? We've all been through a really terrible date where we thought it was going to go really, really amazing and this person has just been rude. They've not been what we expected. It just hasn't turned out right. It's all for the plot. And the first thing I would do is call your friends, laugh about it with them, write about it, post like a funny private Instagram story, just anything so that you can turn away from despair and to laughter because I think if you let those bad dates really get you down, you're going to start expecting a bad date from every single person and then you start acting like they've already disappointed you and then you both end up disappointed. So keep it light, keep it fun,
所有人都经历过。我认为这些故事真的很折磨人，对吧？我们都经历过那种非常糟糕的约会：我们本以为它会进展得极其顺利，结果这个人却很粗鲁，完全不是我们期望的那样，事情就是没有往好的方向发展。这一切都是为了剧情需要。我要做的第一件事就是给朋友打电话，和他们一起大笑，把这件事写下来，发一条搞笑的私密Instagram快拍，总之做点什么，让你从绝望转向大笑。因为如果你任由那些糟糕的约会让你情绪低落，你就会开始对遇到的每一个人都抱有不好的期待，然后你的行为就会表现得好像他们已经让你失望了一样，最终你们两个都会失望。所以，保持轻松，保持有趣，
keep it airy. And remember that if this person has problems that they've projected on you and if they've treated you poorly or just been like a dick, that all comes down to their insecure. please don't let them drag you down as well. Don't let them make you think that you don't deserve love and don't make them think that the next day isn't going to be better because I promise that it will be. Sometimes it is just a numbers game. I don't know, there's so many theories about this.
保持豁达。请记住，如果这个人把他们自己的问题投射到你身上，如果他们对你很粗暴或者简直是个混蛋，那全都是因为他们缺乏安全感。请千万不要让他们也把你拉进泥潭。不要让他们让你觉得你不配得到爱，也不要让他们让你觉得下一次约会不会更好，因为我向有时这真的只是概率问题。我不知道，关于这个有太多理论了。
It's a numbers game. It happens when you least expect it. There's one soulmate for all of us. I think the defining theme of dating in your 20s and reclaiming your power during this period is just to go out there and have fun and be open to the opportunity of romance, even if you've been burnt before. So I want to thank you all for listening if you made it this far.
这其实就是个概率问题。它往往在你最意想不到的时候发生。我们每个人都有一个灵魂伴侣。我认为二十多岁时约会的核心主题以及在这个时期找回主导权的关键，就是走出去，尽情享受乐趣，对浪漫的机会保持开放的心态，哪怕你以前曾受过伤害。所以，我要感谢所有听到这里的听众。
Drop a little rose emoji down below. I love knowing how many of you listen to the full episode. It always makes me feel so, so special. If you have further dating dilemmas or questions about reclaiming your power, also drop them in the comments. I'll be around answering some of them. make sure that you are following us on Instagram so that if you have your own listener question for future episodes you are around to ask them and you know when they are going up.
在下方留一个玫瑰表情吧。我喜欢知道有多少人听完了整期节目，这总是让我感到非常非常特别。如果你还有其他关于约会的困惑或者关于找回主导权的问题，也可以留在评论区，我会抽空回答一些。确保你关注了我们的Instagram，这样如果你在未来的节目中有自己的听众问题，就能及时提问，并且知道它们什么时候会发布。
If you haven't already, make sure you subscribe to us on YouTube. We have video coming out very, very soon and follow along the podcast right here, where you are now. Give us a five-star review, join the community. We'd love to have you around and we'd love to let you know when we have new episodes dropping twice a week every Tuesday and Friday. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle with yourself, especially in today's dating climate.
如果你还没订阅，请确保在YouTube上订阅我们。我们很快就会发布视频。同时，就在你现在听节目的地方关注这个播客。给我们一个五星好评，加入这个社群。我们非常高兴你能加入，并且想让你知道，我们每周二和周五都会更新新节目。但在此之前，注意安全。对自己好一点，温柔一点，尤其是在当下的约会环境中。
And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
就在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。在《回顾过去》(Look Back at It) 播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。对84年我也记忆犹新。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的，和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《难忘的教训》(Learn the Hard Way)。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得怎么做的持证专业人士交流。
many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
许多男人都穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做。在I-Hard电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难忘的教训》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》(Love Trapped)。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们》(The Girlfriends)。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证纯人工。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。